david allport has a landscaping business
he's from nolsley in merseyside an area
where
incomes are low and times are hard
when you're talking about attitudes
where people are struggling
just to stay off when they're told to
because that's all you're doing it's
easy way
his labourer paul is paid by the day a
positive covert test for him
would mean no work and real challenges
if you don't get test positive 40 you
can't have it can you
so obviously like i know me me who's
been on site and they scale at it
and she like he acts as self-isolated so
he told the site and he laid him off
because he have to self-isolate for 10
days so
when it gets to that point especially
you've got kids what at what point do
you draw the height
[Music]
right now knollsley has the highest
covert infection rate in england
and authorities here say it's linked to
high levels of deprivation
the government already gives a grant to
people on lower incomes who have to
self-isolate
and the fact that there was even a
proposal a suggestion
that 500 pounds would be given to
everyone although it's been rejected
suggest they know just how critically
linked finances are
to compliance new figures suggest just
17
of people that's under one in five are
going for a covert test when they have a
symptom
sam briggs has six children and her
partner is a self-employed painter and
decorator
they've had tough conversations about
what to do if any of them
fell ill do you think he'd go out to
work if he wasn't feeling well at the
moment
just because you know yeah you go to it
if you go to work yeah
yes definitely to give us a better one
to make what's happening
as long as we're just taking every day
as it is i'm glad we're waking up every
day
but it is it it is quite awful it's
upsetting
it's tears in our house a lot because
it's frustration
tough new government ads are telling
people to get a test and isolate
a government minister told sky news
today they want to understand the
reasons why people
might not be doing that look them in the
eyes
and tell them you're doing all you can
to stop the spread of covet 19.
they would find answers right here
katherine overtopsy sky news in nolsley